I'm going to answer a question that I get in some form or another quite often,
uh, this one is well-worded and it's from crispy,
who is in a few of the private Facebook groups where I do
testing.
Types. Here's the question?
How does Tim integrate creating artists flow in parentheses being
productive,
getting done in parenthesis self-reflection slash healing and transcendence,
and then in parentheses, going beyond oneself,
be it spiritually contributing to others, et cetera. In his full life.
The crux of the question is what he's learned on living a full life and how he's
learned to allow it all in given that we have the same 24 hours in a day and
365 days in a year,
and each of these endeavors could be all consuming of one's time and attention.
Maybe it's balanced, maybe it's selective focus.
Maybe it's something very different. I'd appreciate.
His view. So the question is how you incorporate it,
these different facets.
Or pieces of the pie chart into your life.
I do not have a perfect answer. I don't think anyone has a perfect answer,
but I can tell you what I have changed in terms of how I think about this
and how I implement it.
That has helped me to trend in the right direction where I feel better.
I feel more holistically integrated, so to speak.
So let's look at this. We have the creative.
Let's call that artistic flow, the productive, getting things done.
Then we have the self-reflection slash healing slash transcendence going beyond
oneself, whether they're spiritually contributing to others.
Or otherwise, my.
Variance is that you will never find.
Mouse. So with that said again, that might sound pessimistic.
The reason you won't find it is because.
You have to schedule it.
If you want any semblance of covering these bases.
In your.
Day to day, week to week, month to month life. In my personal experience,
it has to be calendared and scheduled in advance.
I'll give you a few examples of what this looks like for me.
Let's talk about being productive, getting done. I block out Mondays.
This is a Monday when we're recording right now,
just to give you an example where I will batch certain types of activities that
could be recording videos. It could be phone calls with my team.
I do one-on-ones with my team members.
My employees administrative work is batched on Mondays.
I do a lot of my say podcast,
recording and audio on Fridays.
And you'll notice that I'm not trying to cover the artistic, the productive,
the transcendent, that, that the in one day I used to do that.
And the task switching costs,
the channel switching costs is extremely high for me
personally, it doesn't work very well. There's a lot of grinding the gears,
trying to move between those things. Therefore,
I block out days of the week where getting done,
there are also going to be a certain check boxes that need to be checked off
right now. I have one blog post per week that must be published.
That then gets blocked out in the calendar for writing time,
typically before noon or before lunch on a given day,
that will be my focus for creating before managing, right?
So create before you manage as a blog post that I recently put up on tim.blog,
if you want to check it out, that was reasonably popular.
And those are all prescheduled.
Those are a few examples on a weekly basis being productive on a quarterly
basis.
I also have a content creation week where I will answer various questions,
produce certain types of audio, focus on writing, et cetera,
get a lot done that can then be distributed over the next quarter.
The next three months,
that is a quarterly example of getting things done on the
artistic side. When I am home here in Austin.
I will almost always.
Try to have at least one day per week and it doesn't vary. So this could be,
say a Tuesday for a series of four to eight weeks,
or it could be on a Wednesday. Doesn't really matter.
But the consistency is what matters. I will have a 90 minute drawing lesson.
First thing in the morning,
this is pre input before any type of email or anything that might.
Distract me. I'll sit down.
With an art teacher and work on say.
Whether it's charcoal, pencil paint,
you name it for graphic.
Expression, right?
That is prescheduled pre committed on the calendar.
Then we have the transcendent, the self-healing,
the reflective.
Or introspective. Uh, I will.
Generally speaking at least once a quarter schedule one to two weeks
semi to completely off grid.
This will be in nature and I'm allowed to write, but I'm not allowed to read.
And this could coincide with fasting. It often does, but not always.
And this will be time that is blocked out once again in advance
and preferably prepaid for. So whether there's travel involved,
lodging involved, facilitators involved, who could be say,
breath workers.
They could be experts in some type of therapeutic modality like ifs or
otherwise having these things booked on the calendar so that there is
a sunk cost fallacy that you can use to your advantage. You've already prepaid,
hopefully irreversibly for these things.
Therefore there's a penalty for canceling and you can use the very
exaggerated human tendency of loss aversion to work to your benefit in this
type of example.
So this may seem like a very sterile answer
to a comprehensive big question. For me.
It is very practical answer, and.
That is you have to put it in the calendar. If it's not in the calendar,
it's not real that you are not going to find balance. You have to create it.
You have to fight every lesser tendency that you have.
In my case, that will stymie.
And self-sabotage by putting it into the calendar.
That is the only way that I have found to integrate these various
pieces into my life. And if I do not have them in my calendar,
it's not going to work. Things are going to break.
I'm going to neglect important areas and I'm going to pay the consequences as a
result.
So that is a.
Long way of saying, get it in the calendar, pay for stuff in advance,
commit to people. So you have accountability. And in my experience,
a lot of things take care of themselves after that.